Halle Berry clapping back at critics the
actress reacts to a Twitter post
commenting on her age after she shared a
nude photo of herself over the weekend
but why honey I don't know it's I'm
baffled too and in her caption the 56
year old says in part quote I do what I
want to do love love love and while she
received a majority of Praise from
celebs like Kelly Rowland Megan good and
even sweetie a Twitter user had this to
say quote imagine being in your 50s
still posting news for attention in
menopause when you should be chilling
with your grandkids aging with dignity
is no longer a thing Hallie's still
kicking right well I'm like that
Energizer Bunny I just keep on going I'm
not going to go away I'm here to stay
and that being said Miss Berry didn't
let the hate slide never dare a girl
like me to do anything with the actress
writing quote did you guys know the
heart of a shrimp is located in its head
seemingly sidestepping the negativity
yet shading them at the same time that's
what I do and add inspiring others with
self-confidence to the list three weeks
ago Hallie shared this sultry snap
captioning it quote hump day self-love
beauty is this beauty does you know you
can be as beautiful as you want to be
but I don't really take credit for that
you know if someone thinks I'm beautiful
or not however I look physically I came
here that way what I take ownership in
is is how I live my life who I am as a
person what I believe and what I stand
for how I treat others those are things
that I make conscious decisions about
and that's what I'm I think beauty is
along with a mindful attitude Hallie
also has no problem keeping it real
like in this moment last month when she
struggled to fit into her pants
I am helping you I'm filming it
they pulled out this iconic SpongeBob
Meme poking fun at the situation
Out of Body Experience whether she's in
the nude or fully clothed Holly
continues to rock it all well
[Music]